John Mayer reveals some of his new music  is about his old flame the singer told  the New York Times Thursday that his  song still feel like your man is about  Katy Perry quote who else would I be  thinking about and by the way it's a  testament to the fact that I have not  dated a lot of people in the last five  six years that was my only relationship  so it's like give me this people  thirty-nine-year-old mayor and 32 year  old Perry dated on and off for about two  years splitting for good in 2014 they  even duetted on the song who you love  some have said his huts to ha soho Perry  started a relationship with actor  Orlando Bloom last year but the two went  separate ways earlier this month  [Music]